what's up everyone hey hey I'm currently
doing a live stream and talking about
some of the things that I support Jordan
Peterson on and I've recently been
seeing him in the news a lot on stage
you guys saw with the political
correctness debate with the Munk debates
and just in general I think it's
important to address some of the things
that I do support Jordan Peterson on as
well as some of the intellectual darkweb
things that I support them on and also
that some of the things that I actually
missed when I was trying to get across
everything in my head to Jordan when we
were at the fireside chat in February
because it was difficult to get
everything that I wanted to chat about
out there so one of the first things
that I started talking to Jordan about
were competent hierarchies and dominance
hierarchies and so the reason why he
chooses competence hierarchy actually
makes a lot of sense right and the
history makes a lot of sense when we
look at Neurology and we look at the
nervous system developing over a third
of a billion years now it's crazy that
that is lodged into us as well science
is lodged into US neurology and
hierarchies our law lodged into US and
remember on the show we do our best to
be as nuanced and multivariate as
possible so that's what we'll do right
now as well we'll be very multi very
nuanced here are there forces that
influence the hierarchy that are
tyrannical absolutely there are there is
corruption that is influencing it's
totally true what are those variables
and how much do they influence the
hierarchy is a very interesting question
that we should go and try and understand
the variables and how much of the
hierarchy is influenced by tyranny but a
vast majority of the hierarchy is
influenced by people's competence so my
ability your ability any
one's ability to just make something of
themselves it's more difficult for
certain people to make something of
themselves because they're born in a zip
code where the socioeconomic status is
much lower than in another zip code and
that literature is very clear and it's
totally true
so as we aim to become better and
actualize and climb up this competence
hierarchy it almost becomes a necessity
along the way to figure out how to take
some sort of meaning or purpose from
this climb and a lot of people get lost
along the way including myself at times
so many people get lost if not everyone
gets lost they can't find meaning can't
find purpose in their life and that's
why we see kind of a little bit of a
purpose crisis that's going on
especially in developed countries
there's a lot of people that can't seem
to find purpose and in order to find
that it's a whole hero's journey a lot
of chaos a lot of perseverance and grit
through that and then finding whatever
you care about in in in your in your
world in your life and going and
bringing that to the world and bringing
that value to the world so we didn't get
to touch too much on competence
hierarchies and exactly what percentage
and what variables are the influencers
in the tyranny in the corruption side of
things
how much people are actually held back
for example this is really important to
remember people in the US are you get
many cases of people that are held back
that are of black skin color or of
female and that is just a true thing
that there is that the people do get
held back in that sense from their
potential and if you transport the same
idea structure to China
if you are a white person in China or in
Japan or in Botswana or wherever you are
in the world you are a minority then so
you as a white person it's gonna be more
difficult for you to make impact to
climb up the hierarchy as well so the
general notion of of it being just hyper
localized in one space is also
applicable to all these other places
across the world so it's this constant
intermixing and interchanging of where
are people judging other people based on
their groups and not based on their
individuality and that is a very
interesting idea is to analyze the
hierarchy for competence and for tyranny
where is it tyrannical and what part of
the world how what percentage are these
variables influencing tyranny how much
is it and then we have people like dr.
Vivian Ming that's one of my mentors
from over three years ago that instilled
the words maximizing human potential
into me well she calculated attacks on
being different so in the certain
hyperlocal
areas across the world there's actually
a tax on being different it's more
difficult for you to go and make your
impact because of these strange sort of
of of ways that the hierarchies being
influenced by other people by culture by
different economic dynamics political
dynamics sociological and psychological
dynamics so this being so old and so
baked into us makes this point makes me
want to talk about this point for so
long and I think that's the hilarity of
the lobster that is the hilarity of the
nervous system and of the tremendous
impact that that has on our lives
twenty-five years old to think of
something that's 300 million years old
is it's a joke in comparison in time
length so I can't sit here
with my brain and just think that I know
more than what evolution has put
together over millions of years so I
think that's a that's a that's a that's
a it's an important practice in humility
and it's an important practice and just
knowing that the thoughts that come to
my mind are not these guaranteed
thoughts of correctness that I'm totally
open and willing to let my ideas go in
light of other better ideas so I tried
asking Jordan this onstage on the 17th
of February as well where I talked to
him about the the the the case of a
lobster that has so many different homes
and just prevents other lobsters that
are lower on the competence hierarchy of
getting any of the homes as in it's
almost as though there is an excess of
homes that this top lobster has and it
prevents other ones from getting homes
now is that true in every scenario no
why don't they just go find a home
that's not one that those lob that that
lobster owns well there's a lot of
complication and a lot of variables that
go into this but the general idea is
that if a lot of of materialism or
property in this case homes that this
lobster has are going in the ownership
of this lobster then what
long-term effects does that have on the
community of people that it lives around
the medium lobsters the lower lobsters
on the hierarchy of lobsters and also on
the on the future of that community is
that lobster going to get the best mates
and then decide to be the king lobster
and all the other ones how do they live
do they die off what happens so the the
competence hierarchy is actually quite
fascinating and it's baked into our
evolution in our neurology and there's
been a lot of conversation about the way
that currently male and female is
interact within the competence hierarchy
and
I think that this is a very interesting
conversation and I think many of you
likely remember the conversation where
Jordan I believe it was on Fox was
talking to a reporter a journalist about
an interviewer about how with when when
females do things like add additional
augmentations to their aesthetics then
it makes them more attractive for men as
in when women put heels on or they put
lipstick on or makeup on and that is a
direct relation of the woman's
propensity to want to attract mates at
the higher end of the hierarchy men do
the same thing in a different way men
will work their ass off relentlessly to
try and accrue some sort of competence
in the hierarchy and this is very
frequently seen with like influence or
impact or money that kind of stuff and
then that attracts them higher female
mates as well so that dynamic has been
going on for a really long time between
males and females of trying to attract
mates that are of higher influence a
higher competence on the hierarchy and
it is evolutionarily baked into us all
the way back to the hunter-gatherer days
when it's the show-off hypothesis the
hunting hypothesis that used to come
back from a big hunt and the warrior
that would have the most meat the most
fur the most material that and food that
the village could use the women would be
most attracted to that male and the same
thing in return for the males that if
the males are observing the fee
males and there's females that are
expressing the greatest nurturer and the
greatest emotional intelligence then
males will be very attracted to that as
well and then they rank them higher on
their competence hierarchy in terms of
the responsibility there now is this to
say that it's males are only hunters and
females are only gatherers and nurture
is absolutely not and we don't like that
kind of binary thinking so let's not
let's not do that anymore where we try
and put each other into straw man binary
positions let's keep it very nuanced and
very multivariate and so it's totally
fine for women to go and become hunters
and for men to become nurtures and
gatherers is totally cool so but where
are their skills maximize the best at so
as many times has been mentioned now by
James d'amour and Joran Peterson is that
we funnel into certain categories of
wanting to do certain things as in like
men typically funnel themselves into
engineering roles females funnel
themselves into Social Work nursing and
I mean the truth is that you see that
every time you go to like a hospital you
see a lot of female nurses and you never
think like man I wonder what amount of
tyranny is being influenced on the
nursing system that doesn't allow men to
be nurses well there is a little bit
right just like there is with women
trying to be engineers like men that
come in nursing
you know females and people that are
hiring male nurses omit men have to have
emotional intelligence to be a nurse you
have to have really good caretaking
skills to be a nurse you have to have a
lot of respect for other humans deep
Comeau connection to other humans in
order to be a good nurse so the same
thing applies to when a female goes for
an engineering role there's a lot of
males heavily dominated by males and
engineering and so the females got to
have a lot of logic and a lot of
a not not agreeable nest they have to be
a willing to be disagreeable and they
have to be you know willing to to to
argue with another person is especially
man in that case about something that
they might have the best idea about and
so so then there's these funnels that
occur and so it's actually not healthy
to try and to completely put regulations
on top of people obviously and say that
oh like you know we you have to have
this many hires of this certain group
identity that's not healthy it's more
about the individual and them going and
choosing whatever path they want but the
question is how do you provide every
individual with any path as in no matter
what zip code you're born into can that
child that's still born into a low SES
zip code socioeconomic status can they
still you have the tools necessary for
them to learn how to program especially
like let's say it's a let's say it's a
black girl that's in that's in the South
Dakota where I'm from it's a little bit
more difficult when you're in a state
that's heavily white in order for you to
have your potential maximized just
because there's a lot of ha forces of
like someone that's in a management
position is going to be looking and
trying to hire people and they're gonna
hire other similar people that are like
them like other white people and it's
it's it requires a certain skill to
observe the person as just an individual
and see that oh this black girl that
knows how to code is actually as good or
better than other the other people here
that know how to code so so this applies
to to the height the hierarchy and the
competence apply to so many aspects of
our lives that we don't even that we
haven't even started to analyze and
understand all the different variables
that go into it and we
make it by an area we have to talk about
it in detail and in in all of its
variables because it's very fascinating
is very interesting and it's probably
one of the one of the biggest questions
of our day is that are we going to
continue and we asked this on our show
all the time on simulation is that
although the Pinker arguments true that
this bottom of the hierarchy is slowly
coming up very very slowly that the
people at the very top of the hierarchy
are accelerating at a much more rapid
rate especially with exacerbated by all
these different types of technology so
the question then becomes is like what
do we do in the dominance hierarchy in
this competence hierarchy what do we do
there so that we don't experience some
sort of a tragic bifurcation of the
human species based on socioeconomic
status and that's possible that that
does happen and a lot of people people
that I know are saying things like well
taking care of the poor costs a lot of
money or they're already so mentally and
physically ill it's so difficult to take
care of them at the same time we have a
lot of compassion for them like it's
like holy cow I can't believe that
you're in that mental or physical state
tonight how can I help you how can we
make systems that help you how can we
provide you with a computer or a work or
a the right physical therapy and mental
therapies in order to get on this on on
a path that's productive so that is on
this on this hierarchy of competence
what's gonna happen to this middle area
where the wealth is now being
concentrated a lot at the top and not as
much on the bottom in middle what's
gonna happen to that bottom in middle
how are we gonna figure that out
I challenge Jordan Peterson when we were
on stage cuz he said that people
couldn't be retrained for work and I
said pop probably not in six months but
they could be retrained for work
in six years and six years you can
rewire a whole mind to care more about
the future and these different areas of
expertise that one could learn and work
in so I think that it's possible to
retrain somebody in six years and even
less than that especially with augmented
reality headsets that are immersively
experi experientially immersing people
into the design of an environment that
they're able to engage and interact with
and learn and learn inside of so there
are different ways to retrain people and
how are we exactly going to address that
part of the of the of the equation of
the competence hierarchy as people as we
evolved as a civilization what are we
gonna do about the different
socio-economic statuses it's a really
important question many people were
curious why I referenced Jordan Peterson
being reminding me of Tony Robbins and
the reason why I said that was because
of his rule about standing up straight
with your shoulders back rule number one
and that's you know that's what the
lobsters do their neurology to say that
ah I'm Tony Robbins does that - yes yes
right so that was where I kind of made
that connection I thought that was quite
interesting so so we talked a little bit
about the tyranny versus the competence
and we talked about different places in
the world and how that's affected in
those different places and what we do
about the socioeconomic status there so
that's about competence hierarchies
that's what I didn't get to talk to
Jordan about regarding competence
hierarchies there's a lot more there
that didn't get unpacked I mean we can
talk about in cells really quick I think
this is an important thing to talk about
there's a lot of men that are currently
upset with the hierarchy and that are
saying that they're involuntarily
celibate
and I think that that's a poor excuse
for men to not learn so social social
skills to be able to learn how to
approach women to learn how to fall on
their face when they get rejected at the
same time I understand that there are as
a certain category of men that and women
that are very so socially hesitant to
such a degree that they prefer to be in
their own space only and in that case
then it's then you pretty much only have
the choice of finding somebody else like
that so if you're not willing to go
outside of your social bubble this
comfortability of being alone then you
need to find someone else like that that
only really wants to be alone and then
you can interact just a little and
everything but for all of the rest like
go out there and try go fall on your
face a bunch when you walk across the
bar and you or the museum or wherever
you're at at a meet up at a hike and you
just start talking to someone about what
they care about you know you know what's
your name Oh Kelly gray Kelly like what
do you care about like what are you
building into our world what are you
passionate about and what are your
values and just and just be there with
that feeling of like total
uncomfortability of Ogada at any moment
Kelly could turn around and tell me to
screw off and if that happens like it's
important to pick ourselves up and
persevere and just go on and go forth
and the same thing you know people talk
about throwing wrenches into the into
the hierarchy and making it different in
ways like potentially having female
traits inside of leadership positions at
corporations and I think that's a very
interesting thing that I'll touch on in
a little more detail but in this example
with why can't females approach males as
well they do sometimes it happened to me
as well and and I would highly recommend
that females do approach males I think
that's a very interesting way to throw a
wrench into the equation is for a female
also be like hey like hey Paul what do
you care about you know what are your
values and then and then that would make
a little more friendly conversation as
well across the across the board and
there of course are many ways that that
men need to be a little bit more you
know careful as well especially since
they're you know in many ways physical
and aggressive and and things like that
there are also men they're gentle and
more feminine and females that are more
aggressive so let's touch on this there
was the conversation about about pay gap
although there is a pay gap we don't
know exactly what variables are going
into the pay gap and it's really
important to understand that there's a
lot of variables it's like climate
change it's like health care or
immigration there's so many variables
that go into this complicated equation
it's really difficult to just say like I
objectively know it's this one way and
that's how it exists and that's that so
let's break it down by variables like
why are there less women in executive
roles at companies well this was touched
on really well by Jordan in his Channel
four interview with Kathy Newman but the
the general gist of it is just that it's
men and women take different career
paths just in general there are women
that are willing to be very disagreeable
and women that are willing to work 80
hours to try and climb to the top of
these competence hierarchies but women
also care a lot about nurturing kids and
having families and men are willing to
sacrifice that and their bodies are able
to have that at later ages so there's
these things that come to play now is
there still tyranny that's involved in
the politics of the hierarchy yes there
is we don't know what percentage and
what variables are exactly the
influencers but take into account
feminine traits this is a very
interesting conversation point right now
I've been in my head a lot while I've
been talking to you and because I just
took a breath
and slowed down a little I was able to
drop into my heart a little more and I
was feeling a little more and I think
that the trait of feeling and the trait
of emotion is a little more concentrated
in women than it is in men and so
because of that if we were to take some
of these traits of feeling and emotion
and competence around emotion and how
compassion empathy that maybe that the
workplace could become a better place if
men were more humble in wanting to
accept feminine qualities into the
workplace and maybe the workplace would
become a better place maybe more
agreeable at times but still
disagreeable with seeing which ideas
prevail so that's a little more nuanced
onto what we didn't exactly get to cover
in the conversation about men and women
in the workplace so that's a lot about
competence hierarchies and I'm sure that
I didn't even get to touch on a couple
of the other things I wanted to touch on
like the genetic fitness landscape and
being able to jump from different Hill
to different Hill across different
subjects and the importance of being a
polymath in that sense and I'm gonna
have to probably do another one of these
where I talk about another whole
different category I will I'm gonna do a
whole different one where I talk about
some of the categories just just the
temporary maybe segue into that next one
is that just take into account the idea
that I've posted about which is that you
can't just become a victim to the world
even though there is oppression going on
in certain places and the social fabric
has big tears in it and it's not for
low-income low SES places that are in
zip codes that are specific low SES
areas it's more difficult to pick
yourself up and move
that's totally true then if you're
privileged in an area of a higher more
affluent zip code that makes it easier
for you to achieve whatever you want you
get access to computers to access to
whatever you want but it's also a mental
state and we got to snap people out of
the victim mental state and get them
into the champion mental state into the
individual awakening actualization as
well as building a better social fabric
to get more kids in underprivileged
areas actualized so we need to build a
better fabric but also people need to
snap out of the victim mentality and
move forward so that was another one of
the things that I really wanted to touch
on and you know well we'll get into this
a little bit in the next in the next
shoot but lift yourself lift yourself up
and get going into the world and build
something of value and find purpose find
meaning find really good mentors and
friends and and build really cool
projects into the world that influence
people and make it a better world
together so that's pretty much it
much love thank you for tuning in let's
build a better world together let's
understand how the competence hierarchy
exists and how flattening out things
might not be the best so it's probably a
good idea to figure out how to how to
work within this hierarchical structure
and trying uplift everyone together
otherwise there might be some sort of a
bifurcation and have more multivariate
conversations about what's going on
between men women other other people
that don't affiliate with male or female
as well as people of high socioeconomic
status low socioeconomic status what's
going on in there what are all these
variables that are crunching in and how
can we have better discussion about them
so I want to just you know personally
thank you for tuning in I want to thank
you know Jordan Peterson I want to thank
him for teaching a lot of us about these
things and bringing them
to our attention as well as a couple
other members of the intellectual dark
web that have brought them to our
attention as well so thanks to people
like James d'amour with his initial
Google memo as well as as well as people
like Eric Weinstein Brett Weinstein and
Dave Rubin that are continuously trying
to have these conversations I've made a
couple videos challenging them as well
which is true I do challenge them in
certain ways but I also agree with them
in many ways so thanks for tuning in and
checking out this content I greatly
appreciate it we do here at simulation
we have a lot of conversations about
science and entrepreneurship and so
whenever we stem into something that's a
little bit more political like this we
still talk about the hierarchy and how
that's baked in to neurology and
neurology as a science and evolution is
a science in sociology as a science as a
social science how that's interacting
from wealth from gender from all these
different ways within the within the
hierarchy and in different hierarchies
around the world in China and Russia in
Ecuador in the u.s. they're all
different so similar but different so
thanks again for tuning in if you found
this content useful give it a share give
it a share talk to other people about it
comment below with your thoughts I'd
love to feature some of your thoughts on
our Twitter and Instagram give us a like
give us a subscribe join the family
support us on patreon we're trying to
scale this endeavor to impact more
people hopefully convince some of the
hard hitters in that intellectual dark
web I would love to get like someone
like Candace Owens on the show and talk
to her about some of her thoughts about
this and and other people from the
intellectual dark web so thanks again
for tuning in and I'll catch you on
another one of these broadcasts soon
lots more topics to cover lots of more
variables to touch on so thank you peace